greetings and Happy Thanksgiving to all
of you who may be celebrating today in
the U.S I am Cheyenne Cramer and I am
the Project Lead at the moment for the
We Care Wellness empowerment team and
you know we've been doing a series of
Wellness empowerment seminars over the
last few weeks and even though today is
Thanksgiving and I didn't want to drag
the team out it just seemed like we
should keep the momentum going tonight
and so what I'm going to do tonight is
I'm going to share a documentary with
you it lasts for just about 41 minutes
and it could be a good cure for turkey
coma uh I'd absolutely love this
documentary I love the doctor that it's
all about and you know I encourage you
to watch this documentary because
there's so much that we don't know that
we don't know when it comes to being
able to be self-empowered with our
health
the magic the miracle that's in inside
of minerals
you can't even begin to know uh there's
tons and tons of documentation out there
but it's not taught to our traditional
medical community
you will find some in our community who
have learned something about minerals
but far too many of them know very very
little
and when you get done watching this
documentary tonight
if you are impressed by Dr Wallach and
his message for how we can become more
self-empowered and how we can do more to
help our body's own natural abilities to
improve uh the health and wellness in
our bodies
um you know I encourage you to also take
a look at this YouTube video that's
listed right here I'll probably go back
on on Facebook and YouTube later and put
this link in there
under the the video itself so that it's
easier to click on but this YouTube
video actually is about my husband and
it's about how Dr Wallach helped him
and to me you know most people know if
you know us at all that we are on the
road we are
um we are rvers full-time we're actually
in Central Florida right now and very
grateful for it today uh but we wouldn't
be here if it wasn't for Dr Wallach
because my husband was in so much pain
he was sitting in a chair all the time
watching TV he was depressed which was
making me depressed and we almost gave
up the vision and the mission that we
were supposed to be on because he felt
so physically horrible Dr Wallach saved
his life saved Our Lives saved our
mission
so I'm gonna kind of leave it there and
um it's hard for me to know I see
somebody on Facebook is actually joined
in and is watching thank you very much
Happy Thanksgiving to you as well
um we always encourage people to put
their name in the chat as well because
sometimes stream yard tells us who is
commenting sometimes it doesn't but
anyway thank you for being here and I'm
going to kind of put myself to the side
and we're going to go ahead and watch
the Dr Joel Wallach story and I hope you
enjoy it as much as I do
um it's ah Cindy good to see you uh it's
it's a fabulous fabulous documentary and
like I said if it wasn't for Dr Wallach
we wouldn't be out here doing what we're
doing so thanks so much for joining us
tonight and let me put full screen up
here for Dr Wallach and I just gotta go
and hit the play
and please uh Cindy if you're listening
to this if you could just let me know if
if you can hear it okay if it comes
through the live stream that would be
extremely helpful to me so here we go
[Music]
foreign
obese nation in the world
the medical theory is that people are
obese or overweight because they eat too
much they don't exercise enough I mean
there's two fitness centers on every
corner and every street now
and yet
the number one obese nation in the world
that's because obesity has nothing to do
with lack of exercise or eating too much
his greatest impact on our world is just
helping people understand the benefits
of better nutrition
Dr Wallach has always wanted his mission
to be why you should understand that
your foods do not carry all the
nutritional supplementation that you
believe they carry
the work that he has done for 50 years
it was based on the foundational
fundamental nutrients that your body
needed what the deficiencies of those
nutrients actually meant and how they
all tied together to create an entire
pathology of disease and illness nothing
changes in Dr wallach's Mission it has
changed the world through nutrition if
something is illegitimate false
he calls it out even if it means
alienating the entire medical community
he doesn't care he cares about the truth
he is so brilliant when it comes to
nutrition and Understanding Nutrition
and the need for supplementation at the
cellular level I realized when I was
nine years old as a kid that nutrition
played a great part in diseases that
even doctors didn't know what to deal
with
and that's how this all started
I had facial ticks little cramps in my
face and I'd squeak like a pig and make
funny little noises and it got worse and
worse and worse by the time I was nine
years old it was truly disabled and my
mother took me to quote the best doctor
and she said I can't find anything wrong
with him so the next day in school
everybody else went to lunch I went to
the library and I found a nursing book
so he just started the index under A's
and and went through it and it sets of
calcium efficiency
I had chores on the farm including
feeding some Alfalfa pellets that were
enriched to Little Bull caps and I would
read the little analysis tags on the
back
and it had minerals including calcium
and ran right to the bar and began to
get handful of these little Alfalfa
pellets myself and two weeks time I was
cured
and so when I was nine years old I knew
there was something to nutrition
when I graduated high school
I went to the University of Missouri
they got accepted into veterinary school
first try and by 1961 I was doing
graduate work and pathology doing
autopsy
on animals going for a PhD in pathology
he also studied comparative pathology
which meant comparing humans and and
animals and the pathology that they
either shared or didn't share and back
then it was almost unheard of to be able
to research back and forth between
humans and animals and the the things
that they did share in terms of
environmental impact pollution diseases
in 1961 I ran into the first
recognized Mass die off in pollution in
America I'm only 21 years old a graduate
student I recognize it did all the
chemistries got it prepared for
publication and got it published I gave
Marlon Perkins the old news Omaha wow
Kingdom show a copy of it
because they had worked for him and he
was a good friend and a mentor Marlon
Perkins was the at that time the zoo
director of the St Louis Zoo and he
mentored my father and helped him get
into veterinary school because of his
pathology and his veterinarian he had a
different way of looking thing at
challenges that the average person
didn't that whole Chronicle of education
is very very important to understand
because once you understand that then
you understand why he talks about what
he talks about
I need you to go to Africa in the white
rhino conservation projects elephant
conservation project I don't know how
long it's going to take they're rapidly
disappearing because land was being
gobbled up for farming and ranching and
they require a lot of land for food I
went to um South Africa on that project
it's the schlui and unflowsy Game
Reserve now you have to figure out how
to tranquilize these things put the
darts together and we
kind of crawl through the grass I had to
be within 10 yards to these
six thousand five hundred pound Rhino
that want to kill you and so I figured I
shot him in the rump I could get him to
run away as opposed to shooting them in
the front then they charge it I spent
two years on that project caught over
200 White Rhino about 50 black rhino
and over 100 African elephants so if you
see white Rhonda when a zoo or wild
animal park is either one that I caught
or offsprings when I caught say there's
ten thousand White Rhino in the world as
opposed to 400 than there was back in
1965. so very proud to be in on saving
the species this was my middle daughter
who was born in Africa I delivered her
out in the bush of Africa and this is a
white rhino pelvis that she was kind of
sitting in just for something to think
was kind of cute and laugh at
catching Rhino catching elephant living
off of The Wild Game and Fishing in
Africa it was just really a great life
for a young fellow I was prepared to
stay there forever at that point the
heck with academics Perkins sends me
another letter and says I've got a big
Grant from the National Institutes of
Health to study pollution as a cause of
birth defects and degenerative diseases
and you wrote the first paper in a mass
to off in America from pollution
the big zoos in the United States were
going to use the zoos as the canary in
the mind because there's bound to be a
species at the zoo that's sensitive to
pollution like humans
and you'll do pathology and all types of
humans as well as the animals so I went
back to Washington University in St
Louis this was called the center for the
biology of natural systems it was a St
Louis Zoo in 1960 67 there's a 10-year
project did uh 20 000 autopsies 17 000
some change of over 454 species of zoo
animals and 3 000 human beings it turns
out the pollution has nothing to do with
causes all deaths from natural causes
are caused by nutritional deficiencies
but nobody done 454 species until my
project
what it found was that every vertebrae
whether you're a hummingbird or a
flamingo or you're a turtle or a fish or
an elephant a rat a dog cat pig or a
human being all vertebrates require the
same nutrients 60 minerals 16 vitamins
12 masses Three fatty acids if they're
deficient in the same nutrient all
vertebrates get the same deficiency
disease
nobody ever thought of that before and
that was the beginning of the science We
Now call epigenetics
before there was the word these twenty
thousand autopsies and all these
chemistries and slides went into a 1200
page book that sold for 140 bucks back
then it had never been a book like it
before the disease of exotic animals of
course is one of my great Treasures
because it represented the 10 years of
actual work is in the Smithsonian
Institute as a National Treasure back
then Zeus did not have full-time Zoo
veterinarians and so my father trained
the first full-time zoo veterinarian at
the St Louis Zoo Dr beauver Who he my
father and Dr bover later wrote the book
diseases of exotic animals together and
my father's whole idea was to create an
Information clearing house that was the
very first book ever written to be
shared by zoos and vets all over the
country this is before computers this is
before the web when I moved to Chicago
and worked as a pathologist at the a
Brookfield Zoo and Lincoln Park Zoo the
Shedd Aquarium moved from there to
Jacksonville Zoo and the Memphis Zoo
pathologist my father's impact in terms
of helping animals and his passion
around zoos was expanding on the idea of
open-air zoos in the early 1900s into
the mid-1900s zoos were really places
that had cages and caged animals my
father's work and impact had a lot to do
with creating these open air zoos which
you see today a great example of that is
the San Diego wild animal park where the
animals roam free and where the animals
didn't know they were actually caged
growing up with my father obviously was
was interesting you know as a young boy
we would move from City to city and
initially Zoo to zoo I kind of thought
it was normal I thought everybody grew
up in seasonal I kind of had free reign
and free run a variety of zoos I knew
everybody everybody knew me I was you
know this young little kid Dr wallach's
son and so it was fun growing up uh you
know around the zoos I was approached to
go to Atlanta Georgia and work at the
Yorkies primate center with the primate
Colony there that NASA was working with
to send monkeys into space and so forth
Marlon Perkins put my father on this
path early on that's ultimately what led
to my father making the discovery many
many years later of cystic fibrosis
working as a assistant pathologist at
the Yorkies primate Center doing
research on primates in particular to
further human science and human health
and ultimately that's what changed my
father's Direction really towards human
health there was always that peace
behind me looking for more information
Yorkies had many many things there's
five of these Regional primates that are
scattered around the United States in
this particular one in Atlanta Georgia
the Yorkies Regional priming Center
was being used to train and raise
monkeys for NASA for space travel and it
was my first year there it was winter
time all the people who'd been there for
15 20 years but for the holidays I'm the
new guy on the Block I get left there by
myself
here it comes
I get a six month old
baby monkey
came from a colony of 25 baby monkeys
all with different mothers and fathers
so they're not genetically related with
swims for six years
[Music]
before that monkey died every month the
parents the mother and father each of
these baby monkeys they would take a
blood sample and put in the freezer so
it's six years worth of monthly blood
samples from the parents of these 25
monkeys I mean how perfect is that
did everything on the one nutrient that
was missing hadn't been missing in the
other ones before this group but after
this group that new trip was missing
that's why these monkeys got cystic
fibrosis it's the first
non-human case the ciscoverus has ever
diagnosed in a primary
or any animal for that matter I mean I
was excited because this is really going
to help us research to help kids with
cigar bosses so I had this paper all
ready to go and all the data I had all
my microscopic pictures I had all the
chemistry that I had done all those same
blood samples I had the biopsies from
the 24 living ones I got all prepared
I'm so excited I took it to the head
for the Europeans then I took it to the
hit of the medical school at the Emory
University there I said I'm ready for
publication here I want you to review
everything
and they fired me
because they said oh it's a false series
when my father discovered this case of
cystic fibrosis anything to do with with
animal research was a hot potato and
anything to do with Primate Research was
an extra you know hot potato and my
father's Discovery and belief back then
which is the same today is that what led
to the the death of that infant monkey
and led to cystic fibrosis occurring in
that monkey was a nutritional deficiency
they didn't know what they didn't know
and they were feeding them a traditional
diet of monkey biscuits and saturated
oils and things like that and my
father's point was that the monkey in
question and others were they were
deficient in key nutrients selenium
being one of them vitamin and riboflavin
B and others information is is power he
wanted the world to know this
information they wanted to keep that
quiet and so or it seemed my father was
willing to tell anybody you know he was
he was driving the media attention to
get this message out to get the story
out to get the information out wallet
claims he discovered cystic fibrosis in
the organs of a dead monkey while
working two years ago here at the
Yorkies Primate Research Center in
Atlanta proper selenium levels in her
diet we can if we're correct we went
then we'll be able to prevent what is
called cystic fibrosis so is he a
radical Rebel with a cause without a
doubt and he's the best one at it Dr
Wallach has really put himself in a
position to take on a lot of arrows he
wasn't worried about popularity he
wasn't worried about what other people
thought what he was most concerned about
is how he could impact people and do the
right thing and just simply tell the
truth he has this belief and this
knowledge 50 years of scientific
research and I already know for sure I
don't care if he gets knocked down
another 20 times he will get up that
21st time I've seen my father deal with
a lot of blows that way would cause most
people to just curl up in a ball and
quit when he discovered this case of
cystic fibrosis
he had four kids and my father was
married to my first stepmother and she
wound up dying at that time of
Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma it was
devastating to him he made this major
Discovery and he was excited and then
fired it for it and so they took you
know all that away from him and he was
faced with having to support us for kids
Barry is what and move forward that's
when ultimately within the year I knew I
had to become a physician so I could
treat these kids because they weren't
going to do it
there is a disconnect with the medical
system medical system has failed us very
badly uh they believe their Gene's going
to do their thing regardless what you
eat or don't eat
they think if you have bad genes your
bad Gene is going to do what they're
going to do regardless of what you eat
what you don't eat
well on the handle on the street we're
able to show very clearly
that um I could take
a animal with type 2 diabetes and give
them the nutrients
and in weeks to be gone
I've been doing the same thing in human
beings for over 40 years now as a
naturopathic physician
in order to become a naturopathic
physician
you have to do four years of pre-med
four years of naturopathic medical
school
about a thousand hours of clinical
supervision you have to pass national
boards you have to pass state boards you
have to secure a license to practice
medicine and pursue continuing education
credit every year however the
distinction between naturopathic
medicine and what MD's practice which is
allopathic medicine is that naturopathic
Physicians are taught Therapeutics the
intention of which are to cure the
condition
allopaths MDS are taught Therapeutics
the intention of which are to manage the
condition most nature paths we focus on
the body as a healing machine and
recognize that if you give it the
all-natural materials it needs the
herbals that it needs and you take away
from the body those things that are bad
that impact ill health those are the
things that we need to do to maintain
good health your body's a fantastic
healing machine let's give it the raw
materials it needs your body knows how
to fix itself it wants to fix itself
it's trying to fix itself and it's the
holistic Physician's job to support that
and nobody does that better than Dr
Walker at the end of the day we are not
drug-based beings but we are vitamin
based beings and mineral-based beings
and protein-based beings and
oxygen-based beings and water-based
beings
he believes in you taking your health
into your own hands and he wants you to
have every bit of information you need
to make a decision
you know sir I don't even know you but
I'm going to save your life you know
this will take 25 years off your life
are you kidding me
the biggest misconception about Dr
Wallach is that he's just like he's just
a quack like he's just crazy
and he's like a heretic they use these
types of words
but they're using it not because of his
knowledge
they're using it because of how he
behaves but here's the thing it's no
different than us it's just that most of
us meaning
99.9999 of us don't have a sense of
purpose and Mission like he does and you
want him that way because the greatest
leaders of this world have been that way
and they have been the ones who has been
able to transform Society have made an
impact I think Rebels are passionate
people and Dr Wallach certainly fits
that bill I think you have to have a
little something burning in your heart
if you're going to improve health around
the world yes thought process is so
forward that people sometimes think it's
a little insane what he's saying or that
there isn't truth to what he's saying
but he proves everything with research
if people took time to really understand
then they would see how simple his
message is and how much Common Sense
there is in it the first time I met Dr
Wallach I really didn't understand him I
didn't know how to take him and because
I had never been involved with a person
like that who was sincerely passionate
about what he did He's only seen as this
man who's on a mission traveling 300 350
days a year where's his personal time
where's his family time where are all
those things but we make those moments
count when he is home and the
misconception is is that he's all about
work and nothing can be further from the
truth he really is about having a great
life and having a very full life I have
four wonderful children eight wonderful
grandkids and four wonderful great
grandkids they're all very healthy
because they've been taking the 90
essential nutrients before they were
conceived all through the pregnancies
ever developed in and so I'm very very
proud of their good health my father he
is like a child that never grew up
because he's just constantly going he's
constantly learning and we've all known
children they are excited about life
they go go go go until they finally just
collapse and you know they just crash
and you know much like my ten-year-old
you know he'll go and go and go until he
just is exhausted and my father still
does that
we just eat well
why do we need to supplement if we just
eat well do everything right why don't
we need to supplement
this goes back thousands and thousands
and thousands of years ago when the
universal fuel was wood and when you
burn the wood the carbon and the wood 95
to 98 of what's left that powder or the
minerals that they would put the wood
ashes into the garden as a fertilizer
and then we ate the plants unknowingly
we were getting supplemental minerals by
fertilizing with wood ashes this went on
until
three o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882. Thomas Edison pulled
the switch in the first commercial
electric generating plan within 10 years
every town every municipality and every
city in the industrialized World
converted from what is the universal
fuel
to electricity but they didn't know they
were getting their nutritional minerals
from wood ashes how many minerals are
left over every morning when you fill
your home with electricity zero
we do have an organic non-GMO movement
but organic fruits and vegetables raised
in a soil that's nutritionally dead when
it comes to minerals is still
nutritiously dead a farmer is not going
to get paid to put additional minerals
into the soil he only is going to get
benefit from putting fertilizer on his
crops because that's that's the cheapest
way to get bushels per acre even when
you think you're eating really really
healthy you're still probably not
getting all of the nutrition that you
need and the reason why that is is
because the nutrition that you're
getting is dependent on the nutrition
that you're taking in which is dependent
on the foods that you're eating which is
dependent on the soils that those Foods
were being grown in you're not getting
the nutrients even from that organic
pesticide free broccoli because the soil
that it's grown in is not cared for
us in 1936 he said 85 of our farm cells
are totally depleted they speak
Canadians because there's no more wood
ashes there's no more silt from floods
thank you I think of the greatest idea
we'll come up with fertilizers I
absolutely need three nutrients NPK
nitrogen so all their commercial
fertilizer mpk carrots are beautiful
beans are are beautiful
tomatoes
everything you grow or these fertilizers
these are beautiful but they only have
three elements of them in your 57 chart
if you don't supplement I do have to
give some credit to my agricultural
Professor William Albrecht from the
University of Missouri is an icon Dr
Albrecht developed not only the first
Theory and popularized it that just
because you have two oranges doesn't
mean they have the same nutrient content
and he also
popularize the the idea and the theory
that just because
something has grown in in the soil or on
the ground doesn't mean it's the same as
that same thing grown somewhere else in
different soil that nutrients aren't the
same in in all places his last name now
is actually the most common and popular
soil science quality scale it's called
the Albrecht scale and the Albrecht
scale is the rating of the healthfulness
of Agriculture soil
as a student in the Department of
Agriculture
um on the weekends everybody else is out
going to drink beer and I was blessed to
be with Professor William Albrecht who
is the legend when it came to minerals
in the soil and we would be in his
experimental fields and we would just
sit there and squat in the dust and for
four years he was my mentor my personal
Mentor it was one of the best times of
my life to spend those four years with
him because I really really began to
understand minerals in the Earth
Dr Wallace brilliant Insight was was he
noticed because of the way we Farm
because of processing because of soil
depletion we weren't getting the
micronutrients to Channel all that
energy into the right chemical reactions
so we were functionally the starving
obese there's no minerals coming out of
their ad fertilizer program in the crust
of the earth we can find over 75
different minerals and this is the value
of supplementation what individuals need
to understand that if they want to get
the nutrition that they need then
they're going to need to take enhanced
nutrition in the form of supplementation
when it comes to health and wellness and
nutrition
that Dr Wallach had to shock the world
with a simple
one-liner
Dead Doctors Don't Lie I've been giving
lectures for eight years before that
Dead Doctors Don't Lie don't be a great
title for this audio cast that tape and
immediately skyrocketed
and they actually sold 158 million
copies of that audio test at fake it was
life-changing for people
um you know the message itself around
supplementing nobody had talked about it
like that everybody you know when you
talk about supplementation people say oh
I take my vitamins or whatever my one a
day and um but nobody was talking about
the 90 essential nutrients and nobody
was talking about the fact that you know
multiple diseases can occur because of
um uh deficiencies and that cassette
tape and then later the the book laid it
out so succinctly that it was
life-changing for people we think that
the formula to health is something
incredibly complicated and he's really
simplified it into understanding that if
you give the body certain elements
minerals vitamins amino acid fatty acids
then the body is going to take those
resources and create a better body it
was amazing because it was
originally two and a half hours and yet
people found it so interesting the
information they were so hungry for the
information that became a phenomenon
around the world I've translated into
numerous languages and so the book was
really a continuation of that two to two
and a half hour lecture really filling
in the rest of the story he was an
advocate for salting your food to taste
he was always a proponent of good fats
and and upon it against uh oils and
vegetable oils and larger and this is at
a time that utter was a villain healthy
fats were villainized food scientists
and food lobbyists were advocating for
vegetable oils margarine Not Butter not
eggs not salt not things that were more
natural my father was always an advocate
for things that are more natural these
are simple things that that he was
advocating on that audio tape that he
then filled in the rest of the story in
the book the whole world has flipped to
where this is not controversial
information anymore it's a common
mainstream information and today he's
been proven right that Doctors Don't Lie
as the most widely distributed Health
lecture in history one of the gratifying
things today is of course is to see that
the issues that I've brought forth based
on those 20 000 autopsies
which flew in the face of the belief at
the time that I was quite correct and
that now everybody is going the right
direction and I feel gratified that all
that effort was worth it
the reality is my father is a type A
plus plus plus plus personality he
sleeps very little uh per night he
writes his books on uh you know uh
flights he makes good use of his time he
is very passionate he's very driven
epigenetics is all of my clinical work
and all the continuing science
genetics will determine your eye color
your hair color your skin color as soon
as the sperm fertilizes the eggs your
genetics will determine if you're an XX
female X Y male but as an overextension
of this exciting New Field of genetics
it's epigenetics that is how an
environmental Factor including nutrition
or the lack of nutrition but also
environmental factors like pollution and
what a developing fetus encounters
whether it's lack of nutrients adequate
nutrition chemical exposure good clean
water or bad water epigenetics is
replacing genetics because epigenetics
says that your genes your DNA your RNA
your telomeres requires 16 minerals 16
vitamins well you know so Three fatty
acids that 90 essential nutrients as I
began to lecture around the world on the
subject of epigenetics and starting to
downplay genetics this began to draw
fire from the pharmaceutical industry
from the government from the FDA at the
time it was uninteresting nutrition was
uninteresting to Science And scientists
in general they were sure that genetics
that bacteria that viruses that
pharmaceutical drugs held the answer
that DNA held the answer DNA holds part
of the answer today epigenetics is the
hottest Topic in the field of scientific
research because it holds the key it
holds the key to everything but the the
challenge with epigenetics is that uh
there are so many possibilities he's
never been tied to a certain set of
research or a food company or a drug
company or uh the dollar he's just been
committed to his heart and what he knew
the one thing that people should
understand about Dr Wallach is he is not
going to be stopped he's not going to be
stopped by the FDA no one wants to take
on the FDA
no one wants to go through that battle
Dr Joel Wallach has triggered a health
Freedom revolution in the United States
and really around the world the Deshay
Act was Azure congressional act that
stood in the way of doctors having the
sole right to prescribe vitamins and
minerals Clinton Miller who is the sort
of Cutting Edge person for the National
Health Association and Shar Murphy and I
the three of us would collect petitions
at our various events like four times a
year and we would bring these petitions
to actual committees in Congress and say
hey you can't make vitamins minerals
prescriptions that's like saying you're
going to make an egg a prescription item
here and so people have to have the
right to get these things themselves
without having to get a prescription
from a doctor of course doctors didn't
like that they so they actually had
charges brought against us and have
people arrested we were always chased by
detectives and watches and so forth
since 1994 when the Shea actress passed
there's never going to be a possibility
where somebody's going to have to go to
a doctor and ask for prescription for
vitamin A and vitamin C and selenium and
so forth and we're very gratified about
that and that if anything's worth a
lifetime's worth of work that alone is
worth it so until the Shea was passed in
1994 supplement companies couldn't make
disease risk reduction claims about
their products or their ingredients our
whole goal in enacting the the health
claim petition process which is now
available through the FDA was to be able
to educate consumers on the benefits of
these nutrients and these products with
help of people like Jonathan e more and
certainly people like my father this is
now available to supplement companies to
be able to file Health claim petitions
to be able to better educate the general
public consumers can read a label on a
dietary supplement and understand what
the product's good for and the science
behind it the nutrition labeling and
Education Act followed by the dietary
supplement health and Education Act were
indispensable to opening the door to
health freedom in the United States
without those acts passage it would have
been very difficult to get where we are
today so some of the successes that have
come about because of the First
Amendment litigation and also the change
in the statutory law our omega-3 fatty
acids reducing the risk of coronary
heart disease
folic acid reducing the risk of neural
tube defect births
selenium reducing the risk of cancers
antioxidant vitamins reducing the risk
of cancers and on and on
so since the victory in Pearson versus
shillela where we were allowed for the
first time in American history to
communicate the information that folic
acid reduces the risk of neural tube
defect births when in supplement form
the incidence of neural tube defect
births in this country has gone way down
so when you submit the information
around a health claim petition it's not
a simple process it's very detailed you
have to accumulate all of the known
science The Good the science that
doesn't necessarily support your claim
and the neutral science associated with
the nutrients that you're submitting the
claims for ultimately we wound up
working with Dr Gerhard trouser a long
time mentor of my father's the the most
notable and accomplished author of and
researcher of selenium information and
research we also at the fda's request
sent Dr Philip Wenger another professor
very knowledgeable in Trace elements
selenium in particular as well as
Jonathan e Moore to the FDA to educate
them on the benefits of selenium and the
science associated with the claims that
we had submitted ultimately the FDA
approved our health claim petition and
the associated claims such as selenium
May produce an anti carcinogenic effect
in the body and may reduce the risk of
certain cancers if there weren't Dr Joel
Wallach for example we would not have
been able to produce these results
it takes a person who is a Firebrand
like Wally to explode the barriers blow
them up get them out of the way because
he's insistent on our rights he's
insistent on gaining Freedom that will
allow us to communicate this life-saving
information so once the health claim
petition is authorized we don't get to
patent that information we don't get to
trademark that information it's
available to any company that has that
particular nutrient in their product and
the whole goal was to educate the
general public was not to to patent that
information or copyright it it was to
make it available to the general public
and to help everybody with their health
through that process our government
and the medical system says our children
will be the first generation Americans
that do not live as long as their
parents what a terrible projection and
of course
um I'm not going to allow that to him
we'll work day and night we will work
our fingernails off but we're not gonna
let that happen
has been fighting these types of battles
throughout his career one of the covers
of time had two fried eggs and bacon and
a frowny face and the whole message was
do not eat eggs do not eat butter and
and it was this big move to margarine
and Doc of course in that same time was
like putting the stop sign up saying no
no no we eat eggs in fact we eat a lot
of them we eat butter we don't eat
margarine and he's fighting that bite
people thought he was insane because the
whole world and heck the cover of time
was chatting about no no no this is the
message and here he is swimming Upstream
again 20 something years and on the
cover of time the eggs are back on it's
a smiley face now when we're supposed to
be eating butter and it's not
contributing to heart disease what gives
him that unique perspective and have the
opportunity to have to do thousands of
autopsies on animals there are not many
Physicians who have the opportunity to
do 15 20 100 autopsies Dr Wallach has
done thousands of autopsies you get a
totally different perspective about
what's going on in the human body when
you can actually see it and you see it
at the time of autopsy to remember it
vividly him telling me that it would
take probably 100 years before science
caught up and gave incredibility for
that now I think we're I think we're
mostly there people that I've met have
never ever put 24 7 for 30 years into
one thing that they permanently believed
in like Dr Wallach and his mission for
nutrition for the planet he's had a huge
part in really just opening people's
minds to the the possibilities and you
know really broadening that Horizon when
it comes to health and wellness and and
Better Health through better nutrition
things where he was getting fired for 30
years ago ago now he's winning Awards or
receiving that Klaus Schwartz award was
a justification and a support of my
findings which is an award given to help
professionals who do very unique work
and Trace element research
and I was the first naturopathic
physician to get it usually been given
to medical doctors who were medical
doctors and PhD and either about
chemistry or pathology
here's the experts in Biochemistry of
the world saying my findings were not
only correct but useful Dr wallach's
work was said to be a joke and that he
didn't know what he was talking about
now the United Nations is inviting him
to speak and they're validating what
he's saying there's a philosopher named
Arthur schopenhauer and he's famous for
saying all new ideas are first ridiculed
then bought and then accepted
he is on a mission
and he has this vision of exactly how it
needs to be he doesn't change it's
always who can we help how can we help
them Dr Wallach he still does 300
lectures out of the year does typically
five days a week two hours of radio when
he's doing this radio show he's
typically sitting in a hotel room on the
telephone with a headset and it's all
coming out of his head he doesn't have
someone feeding him answers like there's
other people out there saying this is
the answers you should do I don't think
people realize that they all think
always looking in a book or something
like that no it's just his knowledge I
have seen this guy in the course of one
day do four hours of live radio
two hours of Television interviews a
three-hour seminar travel two hours in
the car and be on the phone every minute
talking to people that called him on the
cell phone to ask him about a particular
Melody that somebody they knew were
dealing with this guy is 24 7. committed
to human vet
our bodies are designed to maintain
health healthy is normal people forget
that that a healthy state is a normal
State everybody always thinks that it's
just me is so it's so difficult or it's
so complex or you have to be so perfect
it doesn't take much for you to be
nutritionally sound but what it does
take is it takes consistency I believe
that the human being has the capacity to
live well beyond return 20. we have a
capacity to and this is epigenetic
because given the right raw materials
ourselves repair themselves forever
today the vast majority of people
understand including the medical world
understands that we need good access to
a baseline of nutrients but certainly
minerals we can't live without minerals
humans would would cease to exist if we
had no access to minerals it became that
message that we need to supplement and
for them to understand that our farming
practices are environmental and
ecological practices have negatively
affected our access to just the basic
nutrition this is where my father's 90
essential nutrients message comes from
is that it's a baseline of trace
minerals including Ultra trace minerals
really a baseline of ultra Trace trace
and major minerals is the key that's the
foundation you can't build a house
that's going to last without a good
foundation you can't build a a a great
uh you know human body without a
baseline of minerals they go around and
get lectures all over the world people
every month bump to me and tell me I
save their lives how the information and
save them up and save their kids they
can't pay for that
you cannot pay for them that's worth
everything
[Music]
wow every time I see that documentary I
get goosebumps because you know that
gentleman and I don't remember them
saying this I think they may have
updated this documentary but he has sued
the FDA 12 times and won every time
you can't do that without having
scientific evidence that's undisputable
and that's one of the things my husband
and I love about him we've met him
personally
um our Mentor that has helped my husband
is a direct friend to his so it has been
a marvelous marvelous Journey so if you
like this documentary well first of all
like I said right here here here in
front yeah there it is right there is a
YouTube video that is my husband talking
about his particular story about how Dr
Wallach helped him
um you know he was he was lining up for
three more surgeries uh and he's had
none of them and he does extremely well
we are on the road because of Dr Wallach
so just wanted to to share that with
everybody today if you found this
documentary to be enlightening please
invite other people to come into this we
care Wellness Group we want to build the
group we want to help more people learn
about the things about health and
wellness that they don't know they don't
know and uh it's just absolutely
amazing to me that so few people
understand
how we can really take more control over
our health and I thank you Cindy for
hanging with us here tonight and
watching this uh I hope you found it to
be interesting I know that you also have
some health and wellness information
that's equally as interesting and that's
what we want to do here in We Care
Wellness is we want to bring together
all types of Wellness whether it's
nutrition whether it's technology
whether it's whatever we want to bring
it to this group and help more people
learn about the things they don't know
that they don't know so invite people in
and uh I have no idea what we'll be
doing next Thursday night but I know
we're getting ready to
um also power up our We Care inflation
beating group so we're also going to be
helping people learn about debt
reduction learning about uh cost
reduction learning about how to build
multiple income streams because if
you're putting all your eggs in one
basket at this point in time with the
economy as shaky and crazy as it is you
could be shooting yourself in the foot
so that's the other pieces we want to
make sure that people are looking at all
the ways that they can fight back this
inflation because we want 2023 to be the
best year that you've ever had so thanks
for being with us here tonight and uh
yes I agree Cindy it is powerful
information and that's why we want to
get it out to more people so uh if
you're in the US hope you've had a Happy
Thanksgiving and for everybody else I
hope you're getting ready for an awesome
weekend I am Cheyenne Cramer and it has
been an honor and a privilege to be with
you here this evening have a great night
and a great weekend everybody thanks